[موسيقى]
من العربيه احييكم انا ريما مكتبي وهذه
نشره الخامسه والتي نستهلها بابرز
العناوين
من بوابه تطوير قدرات بلاده العسكريه
لمواجهه الغرب ويعلن استمرار الحرب في
اوكرانيا
اليوم في اول زياره خارجيه له منذ بدايه
الحرب في بلاده بحثا عن الدعم والسلاح
امنوا طالبان يمنع الطالبات من دخول
الجامعات بعد حضرهن من التعليم الجامعي
والصيدلات عالميه واسعه
السلطات الصحيه الاوروبيه تعلن ان خطر
انفلونزا الطيور منخفض بالنسبه للبشر
وجه رئيس روسي اليوم رساله واضحه للغرب
بان الحرب في اوكرانيا ستتواصل
وستكون اكثر شراسه مؤكدا ان روسيا ستطور
قدراتها العسكريه لمواجهه التحديات التي
يفرضها الغرب عليها واعلن بوتا خلال خطاب
وزاره الدفاع عن تعزيز القدرات النوويه
وتطويرها بنسبه 91% بالاضافه الى تزويد
القوات الروسيه وللمره الاولى بمنظومه
صواريخ عابره للقارات
مسلسل نستمر في تعزيز القدرات القتاليه
والاستعدادات النوويه ما يمثل ضمانا
لسياده روسيا ووحده اراضيها وبشكل عام
الرد على النووي والتوازن النووي في
العالم وقد تم تجهيز القوات النوويه بنسبه
91 بالمئه وايضا تم تزويد قواتنا بمنظومه
فرط الصوتيه وايضا تم تزويد القوات للمره
الاولى بمنظومه الصواريخ العابره
الخاصه نعرفها جيدا ولدينا معلومات دقيقه
لابد من تحليلها لاستخدامها في تطوير
قدراتنا العسكريه ورفع المهارات القتاليه
ايضا لابد من الاستفاده من الخبرات
العسكريه لدى قواتنا التي تعمل في سوريا
بوتن قال انه تم تعبئه 300000 شخص مضيفا
ان المجندين يتدربون بشكل مناسب دون ان
يفي وجودا انتقادات ومشاكل العمليه
[موسيقى]
المجندون يتدربون بشكل مناسب والمواطنون
يساعدونهم حيث يقومون بتزويد القوات
بالاشياء والالبسه اضافه الى ذلك يجب ان
ناخذ بعين الاعتبار الاعتقادات التي
نسمعها المشاكل موجوده لذلك لا يجب علينا
ان نصمت وان نقوم بحل هذه المشاكل
المحلل العسكري واستراتيجي سيد محمد اهلا
بك هل غير قواعد الاشتباك بوتن تحدث عن
منظومه صواريخ عابره للقارات
والثانيان عاد وتحدث عن السلاح النووي
نعم سيدتي يبدو ان الرئيس بوتين قد يعني
لجا الى هذا الخطاب في محاوله منه
لارسال عده رسائل من خلال هذا الخطاب وهذا
ارسال كان يحمل في طياته الكثير من
التحذيرات المبطنه والتحذيرات الصريحه في
بعضها للغرب وايضا يعني يركز في هذا
الخطاب على خمسه محاور رئيسيه في في رايك
محلل لها عسكري واستراتيجي اذا جاهزه او
او اريد هذه المحاور بشكل رئيسي بشكل موجز
جدا اولا المحور الرئيسي الذي الذي ركز
عليه الرئيس بوتين هو ما تتعرض له روسيا
من ضغوطات ومحاولات اضعاف وتهميش من قبل
القوى المناويه وانها استخدمت يعني هذه
القوه استخدمت كل الاساليب والوسائل للضغط
على روسيا في محاوله اضعافها وتهميش دورها
وعزلها له حيث تصبح دوله منبوذه وانهاك
اقتصاده واستنزاف قدرات العسكريه وهذا
وهذه الرساله كانت موجهه للغرب وموجهه
ايضا الى ده بوسي في محاوله من الرئيس
بوتين الى كسب العقول والقلوب وخاصه للراي
العام الروسي وهذا ربما يشير الى ان
الرئيس بوتين يخطط الى ما بعد هذا الخطاب
الى القيام بعمليات عسكريه نوعيه من شانها
ان تحدث فارغا في الايام القادمه وهذا
الخطاب لا يكون عاده الا الا اذا تبعه
يعني اعمال عسكريه ربما تكون يعني وشركه
الحدود هذا اولا الامر الاخر سيدتي وهو
ركز على ترسيخ القناعات لدى القاده
العسكريين والعامه الروس يعني في هذا
الشيء بالذات بانها روسيا مجتهدفه وانهم
في موضع استهداف وانه هنالك محاولات يعني
حديده ومحاولات كبيره لعزل روسيا عن
محيطها والاذارها بمظهر الدوله همم التي
ترتكب اعمال وحشيه وارهابيه وان روسيا هي
تدافع عن حقها في الوجود وتدافع
السياساتها وتدافع عن سيروره هذه الدوله
وتدافع عن كانونها الامر
اخر سيدتي وباختصار ركز على حرب المعلومات
الطاهره واكد بان روسيا تمتلك الكثير من
المعلومات ليس الغرب فقط هو ما يعرف عن
روسيا وانما روسيا ايضا تعريف
تحدثت عن ثلاث نقاط معنويه واعلاميه لم
تتحدث عن المعادله العسكريه سالتك في
السلاح يتحدث عن سلاح اريد ان ان اتحدث
بالمعنى العسكري البحث
الصواريخ عابره للقارات وتطوير المنظومه
النوويه بنسبه واحد وتسعين لم يقل 90 ولم
يقل 95
نعم
بنسبه 91 هذه النسبه بالنسبه للجاهزيه
القتاليه وجاهزيه الاسلحه النوويه هي
تعتبر نسبه مرتفعه مرتفعه جدا وهذا كما
ذكر سيدتي بانه ارسل من خلال من خلال هذه
من خلال هذا التصريح ومن خلال هذا الاعلان
ارسل رساله واضحه الغرب باستعداد وابي
تجهيز وبجهزيه
قوه الردع النوويه الروسيه في مقابل اي
عمل ممكن ان تقوم فيها تقوم فيه الولايات
المتحده او يقوم في حلف الناتو بالمستقبل
وان روسيا قادره على حمايه نفسها وانا
لديها من الاساليب والوسائل والاسلحه بما
يقفل استمرار هذه الدوله وما استقبل بما
يقفل يعني همم يعني وجود روسيا كدوله
كقوه عالميه هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى
سيدتي ركز ولم يركز فقط على الاسلحه
النوويه وركز ايضا على عده امورتهم
العسكري الامر الرئيس الذي اكد عليه وهو
طائرات المسيره ومؤكد بان طائرات المسيره
اصبحت حقيقه واقعه وان هذه الطائرات
ومعلومات هذه الطائرات يجب ان تصل الى كل
مجلد روسي وان كل عسكري روسي يستطيع
استخدامه ويستطيع القيام بتحليل المعلومات
التي ترد من هذه الطائرات وايضا ركز على
كيفيه الحد من هذه الطائرات بالجهه الاخرى
الامر الاخر سيدتي بالنسبه للناحيه
العسكريه وهو ما كانت تفقده روسيا
تعاني من روسيا عسكريا والتنسيق وهذا
التنسيق كان مفقود في العمليات العسكريه
السابقه واذا راينا سيدتي بان العمليات
العسكريه الروسيه في بدايه الامر كانت
مجزئه وكانت تفتقدين الاتصال والتنسيق مما
افقد الكثير من من من زكامها طيب
والمفارقه انا الطائرات المسيره من
الايرانيين ياخذها الروس
ويستخدمها نعم سيدي شكرا لك من عمان كان
معي لواء الركن محمد محمود الثلج محل
العسكري واستراتيجي
في اول يروح رحله له خارج اوكرانيا منذ
بدء الحرب غادر الرئيس الاوكراني فولودو
ميرسيلنسكي الى واشنطن لاجراء محادثات مع
الاداره الامريكيه ادمينا المقرر اي يلتقي
الرئيس الامريكي بعد لحظات ويعتزموا
الرئيس جوبيا الاعلان عن حزمه اسلحه جديده
لكيف تشمل لاول مره صواريخ باتريات بينما
يستعد الكومبرس لاقرار مشروع قانون
الميزانيه العمل الدوله الفيدراليه والذي
يتضمن مساعدات جديده لاوكرانيا تبلغ
قيمتها 44.9 مليار دولار
احد كبار مساعدين رئيس الاوكرانيا بحيلو
بدول ليلياك قال ان زياره الاخير لواشنطن
مهمه للغايه ان ستضع حدا لمحاولات روسيا
اظهار ان العلاقات الامريكيه الاوكرانيه
تشهد فتورا على حد قوله كما انها ستشكل
فرصه لشرح حقيقه الوضع في اوكرانيا
والاسلحه التي تحتاجها كياب في حربها ضد
روسيا والسبب وراء الحاجه اليها وقال بدل
اياك ان نازليسكي سيطلع النخبه سياسيه
الامريكيه على اهميه انهاء الحرب بالشكل
الملائم اي وفقا لشروط مناسبه
ينضم الينا بنت ياف ماكسيم يعني استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه الطيران
الوطنيه بكياف اهلا بك اااه نبدا اولا
ببعض الاجواء التي توحي بانه ربما المجتمع
الدولي تعب من هذه الحرب بسبب تبعات هذه
الحرب على اوروبا اولا وايضا التضخم يعني
فاقمت بمشكله
التضخم همم
فهل هناك محاوله لتمديد امد همم الدعم
اقله من واشنطن لهذه الحرب وعدم الوصول
الى التسويه مع
موضوع الساعه
الظروف فان الدعم الولايات المتحده وزياره
زيلين سكي الى واشنطن في غايه الاهميه
السكان بعض الدول الاوروبيه على وجه خاصه
يرغبون بيتوصل الى هدنه السلام في اسرع
وقت وفي نحن نتحدث عن اوكرانيا
امين
في العالم
وحققنا نجاحات ولم نفشل ولكننا ايضا بحاجه
الى دعم ال الغرب
اولها واهمها الولايات المتحده لان اكبر
الدعم ياتينا من الولايات المتحده وبلا شك
اذا ما اخذنا بنظر الاعتبار انظروا في على
ارض المعركه
المستمر على البنى التحتيه خاصه
هنالك
الان مثلا نتواجد في الملجا وهو المكان
الوحيد الامن الذي يستطيع ان اتحدث به
معكم
فهذه الاوضاع همم
جدا خاصه
نحن بحاجه الى منظمه الدفاع جوي
وبالشكل خاص الصواريخ
الصواريخ هنا لكن معلومات كثيره مفادوها
ان روسيا وايران
حول تزويد ايران للصواريخ الى روسيا
وبلا شك علينا ان ندافع عن انفسنا
وسيكون هو الموضوع الاهم خلال زياره
يعني تم تسريب معلومات عن فطور في العلاقه
بين امريكا
واوكرانيا عن ان احد
الاتصالات المتحده الامريكيه بالمزيد من
الاسلحه ويقنع دا في عيد ضرائب يعني هناك
راي عام امريكي ايضا ليس بالضروره مع هذه
الحرب في المئه
نوباني
ولكن استطعت الرئيس تظهر بان اغلب امريكيه
يدعمون اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب وحتى دعمونا
المزيد المساعدات العسكريه والماليه
لا استطيع ان اقول بان هنالك فطور في
العلاقات وربما في العام الماضي همم
زياره رئيس لم تكن ناجحه جدا ولكن همم
خلال اشهر العشره الماضيه
منذ بدي الغزو على الاراضي الاوكرانيا فا
كانت هنالك اتصالات بين الرئيس اوزنسكي
وبعيد
وكانت افضل من قبل اعلى عن ذلك رئيس
الوزكي والرئي سبايدر مان غرد انه يتطلع
للترحيب بالرئيسكي
[موسيقى]
يدعم منك الى الحز بين الجمهور
والديمقراطيه في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
وشاهدنا ذلك
التبني القرار الاخير اللي دعمنا
واتمنى ان يتمكن الرئيس يتحدث امام مجلس
الشيوخوان ان يعبر عن حاجتنا لدعم
الولايات المتحده
ابقى معي لو سمحت ساتحدث بالمزيد من
التطورات الدوليه ففي مقابل هذه التطورات
جدد رئيس الفرنسي من اول ما كونوفي وفي
مقابله بثت على شاشه اف ام
الفرنسيه همم جدد موقفه او ال سي جدد
موقفه بان تحقيق السلام يتطلب من روسيا
ضمانات امنيه لو جرت مفاوضات سلام
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون يقف
منفردا في وجه اوروبا مواقفه المتفردته
فيما يخص الحرب في اوكرانيا تثير حفيظه
الدول الاتحاد فراغم الدعم الفرنسي
لاوكرانيا ورفض الحرب يتفاهم ماكرون
مخاوفيا من وصوله حلف الناتو لحدودها
الغربيه ونشر اسلحته هناك ولي لتهدئه تلك
المخاوف والمره الثانيه خلال شهر يطالب
ماكرون بمنح روسيا ضمانات امنيه في حال
جرت مفاوضات السلام لانهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
من يلوموني على التفكير في مثل هذا
الموضوع فليشرح لي ما الذي يقترحه
الرئيس الفرنسي لم يكتفي بهذا بل حذر من
ان رفض منح ضمانات لروسيا قد يشعل حربا
شامله في القاره باكملها تصريحات اثاره
انتقادات عالميه ومبطنه للرئيس الفرنسي
ليس من كيف وحدها بل من قاده في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ذهب بعضهم الاتهام باريس
بالتسامح مع موسكو
المخرج من النزاع الاوكراني يكون من خلال
تقديم ضمانات امنيه لاوكرانيا اما بالنسبه
لروسيا سنتحدث عنها لاحقا
في المره الاولى وبعد تعرض الرئيس الفرنسي
الى هجمات زملائه من قاده اوروبا دافعه
حينها قصر الاليزا عن الرئيس بان تصريحات
مكرون حول منح روسيا ضمانات امنيه اخرجت
من سياقها لكن في المره الثانيه الرئيس
الفرنسي دافع عن نفسه قبل ان ينتهي من
تصريحاته لاعلامه المحلي بحثه لزعماء
اوروبا على شرح البديل الذي يقترحونه
للمحادثات النهائيه مع الكرم قبل ان تشمل
نيران الحرب شرق اوروبا القاره باكملها
حنان المصري العربي
[موسيقى]
واعود الى كيف وضيفي مكسيما لاستاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه الطيران
الوطنيه
اوروبا هي من تدفع ثمن الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا اكثر من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واول على اخر موضوع السلام
سيبحث اذا لم يكن
عام 2023 سيكون في العام المقبل ااه هل
تؤيد كلام الرئيس مكروه هناك تنازلات على
كيف انتم تقدمها اول على اخر
ماستر
عليه ان يخاطب جمهوره لان ماريا ليبان
كسبت 40% من الدعم
[موسيقى]
وعدم اتحدث عن علاقات سلامه ماكرون
بالتاكيد يجب ان ناخذ بنظر الاعتبار
مثل هذه المواضيع هذه الطرحات في امام
المجتمع الفرنسي وليس كل الفرنسيين يدعمون
همم
عايز فوز همم موسم
اتخذ القرار اللي همم التقديم المزيده من
الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا
عبر مرارا من ان هذا الدعم العسكري من
فرنسا سوف يستمر
الى ان تتوقف حاجه اوكرانيه لها
الاتحاد الاوروبي ولايه المتحده لم تقراني
بعد بان هذه الحرب
تستمر الى ان يستقيل رئيس بوتن
فهذه المفاوضات سوف تكون معهم او مع رئيس
بوتن ولا بد ان تكون هناك بعض التنازلات
ضروريه من اجل الجلوس
المفاوضات الى الان لم
تتوافر مثل هذه الظروف
لوما كبير الرئيس ماكرون ولكن مع ذلك اذا
ما بدات المفاوضات فسوف سوف تحصل يوم معك
فا على الارجاح ستكون مع رئيس بوتين
وعلينا التحدث معهم الوطنيه
ايران بسبب مشكلات في دفع الرسوم
احييكم من جديد اعلنا طالبان تعليق تعليم
الفتيات في جميع الجامعات الحكوميه
والاهليه وذلك في جميع البلاد بناء على
قرار مجلس الوزراء القرار لا رجعه في عن
اولاد رجوع عنه وقد منعت قوته الامن
الفتيات من دخول الجامعات اليوم
ها
عزيزه ابدالي طالبه جامعيه تدرس في كليه
الطب منعتها طالبان من الذهاب الى الجامعه
تقول ان طموحاتها قد ذهبت ادراج الرياح
كما ذهب طموحات زميلاتها
من تحقيق تلك الاهداف اضمن حل املنا في
الوصول الى اهدافنا
يصدر هذا المرسوم في وقت اغلقت المدارس
فوق الصف السادس الابتدائي امام الفتيات
الافغانيات للنحو 16 شهرا ما اثار
انتقادات داخليه لم تؤدي الى نتائج ملمسه
ليس لدينا خيار اخر لمواصله الدراسه داخل
البلاد فاذا اردنا الدراسه علينا المغادره
للخارج
[موسيقى]
اثار ادانات دوليه
للتراجع عنه
طالبان تبرر قرارها بانها تنشغل
فيما الفتيات الافغانيات غير مقتنعات بهذه
التمريرات لان طالبان على سده الحكم منظر
نحو 16 شهرا وكان يجب عليها ان تتغلب على
هذه المشاكل ايا كانت عبده نادر العربيه
كابول
معي من برلين دكتور فهيم سادات رئيس قسم
العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه كردان سابقا
دكتور اهلا بك هل حركه شعبيه معارضه لهذه
القرارات تكفي لقلب هكذا قرارات من قبل
طالبان لماذا لا يخرج الناس في الشارع
لوقفه هكذا قرارات
ضد تعليم الفتيات في البلاد وهذا يوم مظلم
في التاريخ الافغاني المعاصر اما يخص
المعارضه فا الى الان همم كانت هنالك
تظاهرات
بين الحين والاخر ورده على الطلبه بشكل
عام هي على الشوارع محدوده
واغلبها عبر تويتر
وتواصل الاجتماعي بشكل عام
الناس عنده
والى ان يكون هنالك تظاهرات واسعه
تقودها المراه الافغانيه ومدعوما من قبل
الرجل الافغاني في شوارع كابل فان قرارات
طالبان لن
يتراجعوا عنها
وقف مرحله التدريس الابتدائي والثانوي
للفتيات ام فقط الجامعي برايك
المدارس الابتدائيه والثانويه المفتوحه او
مدرسه ثانويه مغلقه اصلا
والشعب الافغاني كان يتوقع من اعاده فتح
المدارس الثانويه
ولكنها طالبان اتخذوا خطوه اخرى
بوابه التعليم العالي في وجهي الطالبه
الافغانيات
والسبب الذي قدموه الافتقار الى البيئه
المناسبه والمناهج المناسبه وبعد
التقديم
او بعد التخلص منها
ابواب الجامعات ولكن
حتى مع لكن
القدرات الحاليه فا
هنالك افتقار او قله عدد بين الاساتذه
الجامعيين فلو فصلوا بين الرجال والنساء
والفتيات والفتيان بنات الطلبه فكيف سيكون
شكل البيئه همم بنسبه الى هم ستكون مناسبه
للطالبات لاكمالي تعليمهن ولكن كيف
سيلعبون هذه الاحتياجات وكيف
سيجدون استاذين واحد للطلبه والاخر لي
الاطالبات
لا يوجد العدد الكافي لذلك اعتقد بان
طالبان بالشكل او باخر
يحرمون الفتيات من الدراسه من اجل التواصل
الى تنازلات من المجتمع الدولي وارضائي
على عناصر المتطرفه في حركتهم لا اعتقد
انهم سيكونون قادرين على توفير البيئه
المناسبه او حتى المناهج الاسلاميه
المناسبه التي يتحدثون عنها في اي وقت
قريب في افغانستان
خاصه
المالي
وقدراتهم الاخرى
ابقى معي لو سمحت خطوه طالبان حظر التعليم
الجامعي للنساء اش على موجه انتقادات
دوليه واسعه وقد افاد بيان للخارجيه
السعوديه بان المملكه تعرب عن استغرابها
واسفها لقرار حكومه تصريف الاعمال
الافغانيه بمنع الفتيات من حق التعليم
الجامعي وذكر البيان ان السعوديه تدعو
حكومه تصريف الاعمال الافغانيه للتراجع عن
قرار منع الفتيات من حق التعليم كما تعتبر
السعوديه قرار منع الفتيات الافغانيات من
التعليم الجامعي يتنافى مع اعطاء المراه
حقوقها
قرار طالبان حظر تعليم الجامعي للنساء
لاجل غير مسما اشعل عاصفه ادانه داخليه
وخارجيه داخليا هذه المره بعيدا عن
المنافسه السياسيه عبر زعيم الحزب
الاسلامي الافغاني كلب الدين حكم تيار عن
رفضه لقرارات طالبان الاخيره واصفا اياها
بالمخزيه هذا القرار غير عقلاني بمنع
الفتيات من الدراسه في الجامعات يجب فهم
الاولويات وتجنب القرارات غير المجديه
قال وزير الخارجيه الافغانيه السابقه
منع الفتيات من الجامعه
الاسلاميه وحقوق الانسان حرمان الفتيات من
التعليم
وتقدم افغانستان ومستقبلها لخطر حقيقي
الافران وتحذر من ان ذلك سيكلف الحركه
مزيدا من العزله
ينبغي على طالبان ان تتوقع ان هذا القرار
الذي يتعارض مع الالتزامات التي تعهد بها
مرارا وعلنا لشعبهم سيترتب عليه تكاليف
ملموسه
الامم المتحده بدورها استنكرت حرمان
الافغانيات من حقهن بالتعليم وحذرت من ان
ذلك مؤشر للمزيد من سلب الحقوق الاجتماعيه
بلوا حتى السياسيه من جانبه استنكر بيان
منظمه التعاون الاسلامي الشديد اللهجه
قرارات طالبان مذكرا بان المنظمه الصدقه
ان حضاره الحركه نوفمبر الماضي من مصر تلك
التصرفات
سين ستطالبان لقد رفضا على مستوى
الاكاديميين في افغانستان ودفعت البعض
منهم للتعبير عن ذلك بالاستقاله في معرفه
اصوات الافغانيه مطالبه بمظاهره حاشده في
كافه انحاء البلاد
من القطاع التعليمي في افغانستان كنوع من
الاعتراض على قرار حكومه طالبان وقف
التعليم الجامعي للفتيات ومنعهن من الذهاب
الى الجامعات اذا الاستاذ جامعي في
افغانستان همم يعلن استقالته من التعليم
همم كان نوع من الاعتراض على هذا القراءه
اعود لضيفي من ابلين دكتور فهيم سادات وهو
رئيس قسم العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه كندان
سابقا همم يعني تعقيبا على كامل كلامك كنت
تقول انه يجب ان يكون هناك حركه من قبل
النساء والرجال ربما ان حركه ما ربما بدات
في صفوف الرجال ايضا سؤالي عن رده فعل
المجتمع الدولي من يؤثر على حكومه طالبان
من مجتمع غربي او حتى من دول عربيه معينه
لقلب هكذا قرارات او ال عوده عنها
الدولي لان المجتمع الدولي نفسه والوجه
خاص للولايات المتحده وبعض الدول الجوار
هما الذين
اقنعونا بفكره النسخه الجديده من الطالبان
والان نرى ان هذه النسخه او هذه الفكره
كانت كذبه هو نفس طالبه لتسعينات القرن
الماضي وبنفسي التشدد
اه
اه اكس بيك لا يمكن التوقع الكثير مجتمع
الدولي لانهم يعرفون طالبان اصلا
والمجتمع الدولي وخاصه الولايات المتحده
هم الذين اقنعوا الشعب الافغاني وبعض دول
الجوار بان طالبان هذه المره اكثر
واعتدالا ويدركون واقع على القرن الحادي
والعشرين
هم الافغانيه الجديده
ولكن
كما نرى كل هذه الوعود فلاشه
ولكن مع ذلك اقول بان منظمه التعاون
الاسلامي
او الدول مثل قطر وتركيا
وربما باكستان او حتى الصين وروسيا او
الامم المتحده عليها ان تفكر بشكل جدي ا
اه بتعاونها ودبلوماسيتها مع طالبان لكي
يقنعوهم بان احلام اربعين مليون شخص من
شعبهم
والواقع اليوم وما تحتاجه فان
استعمل فيها افغانستان مختلفه مع كل الدول
العالم الاخرى
فكل دول حتى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
مثلا تسمحوا للمراه باكمال دراستها ولا
يكون ان لا يمكن ان نكون مختلفين عنهم ولا
يمكن حضاره طالبان يجب ان توافق على باديه
عامه
سابقا
علقت عشرات وسفن تجاريه المحمله بالحبوب
والسكر قبله الموانئ الايرانيه بعد تاخرها
لاسابيع
بسبب مشاكل في دفع رسوم واظهرت بيانات
تتبع السفن عدم قدره السفن على تفريغ
شحناتها مع وجود مالا يقل عن اربعين ناقله
سائبه عالقه خارج من اي بندر الخميني
وبندر عباس وهما من الموانئ الايرانيه
الرئيسيه وقالت منظمه الموانئ والملاحه
البحريه الايرانيه في تقرير لها ان نحو 37
سفينه تحمل اكثر من مليونيه من البضائع لم
تتمكن من تفريغ حمولاتها بسبب مشكلات
متعلقه بالمستندات والسادات بالعمله
الصعبه
هكذا المركز الاوروبي للمراقبه والوقايه
من الامراض
انفلونزا الطيور الاكثر فتكا التي واجهت
اوروبا طالت قطاع الدواجن وطيور وانا تحيل
خطر العدوى يفيد بانخفاض الخطر بنسبه
للمواطنين في اوروبا حيث تتراوح بين
منخفضه ومتوسطه وذلك خلال الفتره من شهر
اكتوبر 2021 الى شهر سبتمبر 2022
وذكرت تقرير عن الوباء تفشل في 37 دوله
اوروبيه وادى الى اتلاف 50 مليون طائر في
البلدان المتضرره
من بريكسال مراسل العربيه نور الدين
الفريدي نور امس كان هناك تحضير شديد
اللهجه انه موضوع انفلونزا الطيور سيكون
خطر جدا على البشريه اليوم هناك تراجع
ماذا ما الذي حصل
ريما البارحه عندما صدر البيان بين المركز
الاوروبي للوقايه من الامراض ومراقبه هذه
الامراض لكنه يرى في التقرير ان هذا
الفيروس لا يزال وجودا سواء كان بنسبه في
صفوف الطيور البريهتي وايضا للدواجن ويقول
ايضا ان
العدوى مرشحه لان تزدادت اتساعا في
المرحله المقبله خاصه في الضياعات ذات
الكثافه العاليه في ضيعات الدواجن الكثافه
العاليه يقول التقرير ايضا ان الفيروس
الذي
رصده العلماء رصده همم 11 نمط
اوراثيا لهذا الفيروس ثلاثه انماط وراثيا
انتشرت في اوروبا في الصيف الماضي وثمانيه
انماط وراثيه
جديده منذ رصدها العلماء منذ شهر سبتمبر
الماضي الاسد ايضا وجود حالات انفلونزا
الطيور لدى الثدييات في المناطق البريه
والاهليه ايضا
وبالتالي هناك مخاوف حقيقيه بالنسبه
وتحذير حقيقي بالنسبه للجانب المركز
الاوروبي للمراقبه ومراقبه الامراض بان
هذه العدوى ربما مرشحه لان تتسع وتتفشى
اكثر فاكثر هناك حالات قليله
لانتقاله هذا الفيروس في صفوف البشره
حالات قليله جدا في اسبانيا في الصيني في
فيتنام وفي كلمه اخيره ان التحليل منخفض
بالنسبه لعموم السكان وانه من منخفض الى
الى متوسط يعني درجه خطر بالنسبه للعاملين
في قطاع التواجد الطيور
وفي نشره المساء او الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
اضراب والف طواقم السيارات الاسعاف في
بريطانيا
يوافقم ازمه القطاع الصحي
[موسيقى]
حه
نشره الخامسه الوطنيه
مين لندن بوراسات العربيه عروب عبد الحق
امامنا اسابيع ساخنه جدا في بريطانيا
الممرضين وايضا السكك الحديديه وباقي
القطاعات ومطار هيثرو اليوم بدا مع
الممرضين
كيف ينعكس هذا على المرضى خاصه انه اصلا
تعاني خدمه صحه الوطنيه
وهو المقر الرئيسي لاداره سيارات الاسعاف
في لندن منذ الصباح تجمع العشرات من عمال
او موظفي سيارات الاسعار
تاريخي يحدث لاول مره في يعني اكثر
القطاعات اهميه بالنسبه
للصحه لقطاع الصحه الوطني هنا في همم في
لندن وهو ياتي بعد يوم من اضراب الممرضين
الذي كان امس في ثاني يوم لهم مما يعني ان
هناك ضغط كبير على القطاع الصحي التوصيل
من الحكومه يعني جاءت بتوخي الحذر اليوم
عدم الانخراط في الانشطه خطيره كما قالت
ولكن يعني من غير يعني لا نعلم اذا كانت
هذه التوصيه طيب بالنسبه لبلد مثل
البريطانيا يعني لندن فيها حوالي ثمانيه
في فصل 9 مليون شخص والمدربين عن همم
والمطربين اليوم 10 الاف موظف من سيارات
الاسعاف وهذا رقم مهم جدا وانه الحالات
همم حالات القلب اولويه طيب كيف بيعرف شخص
على الاتصال اذا كان بنك اتاك او اعرض قلب
يعني من الصعب احيانا التفرقه طيب عروب
بعد في سؤال ماذا يريد هؤلاء ما هي طلبات
الممرضين والامبلنس همم خدمات الابلنس
يعني الموظفين في مجال الاسعاف لم يطلبوا
نسبه معينه لزياده الاجور بخلاف الممرضين
الذين طلبوا زياده بنسبه 19% ولكن هناك
كانت زياده بنسبه
4,7-7-5% وهم يقولون بان هذه الزياده
زياده مهمه بحقهم باعتبار انهم الاكثر
كانوا متضررا خلال جائحه جائحه كورونا
الخلافات طبقه بين الحكومه والنقابات
التي رايناها اليوم احتاجها تقول بان بان
الموظف السيارات الاسعاف وهم لم يقبلوا
المرضى الحكومه هي التي خذلت المرضى بسبب
رفضها همم
بريطانيا مقبله على اضرابات من يريد ان
يذهب هناك من العالم العربي ويتابعنا عليه
توخي الحذر لانه حتى
يعني يشهد ربما بعد التاخيرات شكرا لك
مراسلات العربيه عروب عبد الحق
بعد ما صرح الملياردير لهم ماسك باحتماليه
افلاس تويتر توقعات شركه مستثمره في تويتر
تحقيق خمسه اضعاف اموالها في خدوني سنوات
قليله
تسريحه جماعين للموظفين واستقالات
المديرين التنفيذيين وتراجع مبيعات
الاعلانات وتعليق حسابات مستخدمين بارزين
تخبطتنا عديده تمر بها تويتر بعد استحواذ
الملياردير الى الماسك لها ورغم كل
مشاكلها توقعات اكبر المستثمرين الذين
انضموا الى صفقه ماسك لتويتر بقيمه 44
مليار دولار تحقيقه ما يصلوا من اربعه الى
خمسه اضعاف اموالها في غضون سنوات قليله
مع وجود مخاطر لهبوط محدود النسبيا شركه
عاليه كابتل الامريكيه استثمرت بقيمه 360
مليون دولار الى جانب دمشق في صفقه شراء
تويتر
229 مليون مستخدم النشط يوميا على تويتر
كانوا تاريخيا اقل من حيث الدخل هذا وتقوم
حاليا لجنه التجاره الفدراليه الامريكيه
بتوسيع
في معالجه تويتر لخصوصيتي واماني بيانات
المستخدم مع موافقه الشركه بدفع غرامه
قدرها 150 مليون دولار فيما يلي تسويه
مزاعم بانه اساء استخدام المعلومات الخاصه
بحسب اللومبرج وفي جديد تسريح موظفي تويتر
تعرضت الشركه لعشرات الشكاوي القانونيه من
موظفين سابقين يقدروا عددهم بمائه متهمين
الشركه بيرتك بانتهاكات قانونيه مختلفه
بما في ذلك استهداف النساء وعدم دفع
تعويضات الفصل الموعوده وانهاء العمل بشكل
غير قانوني للموظفين الذين كانوا في اجازه
طبيه اويه علاوه على هذه التطورات
القانونيه يشارك حاليا المليار داره
تنفيذي في بحث طويل الامل عن رئيس تنفيذ
جديد لتر وهو منصب قال انه لا يريده احد
حقا وفق قوله العربيه
وهذه وقفه مع ابرز احداث فبراير لهذا
العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله
توصيل
[موسيقى]
ابراهيم ابراهيم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
شكرا المتابعه